depuis le ciel du Dombas un drone
cherche sa cible
rapidement repéré le char russe est
frappé
ces engins volants modifiés par les
Ukrainiens sont régulièrement utilisés
pour neutraliser les défenses ennemies
trop et le commandant d'une unité
spéciale de drones appartenant à la gare
de nationale ukrainienne
entrepreneur dans la tech en temps de
paix il modifie désormais des drones
commerciaux
reconnaître l'adversaire et l'atteindre
à moindre frais et en un temps record
[Musique]
ça ce sont des drones civils que nous
utilisons pour le renseignement
militaire notre objectif c'est de voler
à très grande vitesse afin de repérer
l'ennemi cette technologie a été un
facteur déterminant dans les récentes
territoriales dans le nord-est de
l'Ukraine les forces armées expliquent
avoir regagné plus de 2400 km² en
l'espace d'un peu plus de deux semaines
retour à la base
ici les drones modernes côtoient des
stocks de munitions datant de l'air
soviétique
abandonné à la faveur de retrait russe
précipité
elles sont désormais détournées par
Nitro et ses hommes et réutiliser contre
leur propriétaire
on a trouvé ces gonades sur des
positions désertées par l'ennemi donc au
final elles nous ont été fournis par la
Russie par Poutine et on compte bien les
leurs rendre
les forces ukrainiennes restent
surclassées par la puissance de feu
russes elle compte donc non seulement
sur les drones tactiques turc by raktah
mais aussi sur des engins faciles à
obtenir
nous avons des drones minuscules qui ont
l'argument une charge explosive peuvent
détruire un char qui coûte 3 à 5
millions de dollars
concrètement cela signifie que nous
voyons et entendons mieux que la
soi-disant deuxième plus grande armée du
monde
de se bataillon ont
été craignaient sur le front sud en
pleine contre-offensive dans la région
de Helson
une guerre aérienne pour consolider les
reconquêtes territoriales et des par des
pilotes qui n'ont pas acquitter la terre
ferme